I'm Tony Chi and I am Scout Master with Group 150 in New York, New York.
This edition of Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by factors like me.
Clark, great show, I'm a new listener and you've got the great work.
And now to you, Scout Master.
Two Scouts go out on a hike to practice their GPS skills
And Tom looks around and he says: you know what? I think we're lost.
And Andy looks at his GPS and says no, no, we're not lost.
There should be a gorilla holding a barrel straight ahead.
And Tom sighs and says: oh man, now I know we're lost.
That's not a GPS, That's your Game Boy.
Hey, this is podcast number 290..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Hey, we heard from our buddy, Ken Anderson, with the 5th Brooklyn Group
of the Baden Powell Service Organization, or the BPSA.
Things are going well. We're bursting at the seams.
We have about 40 otters, 40 timber wolves and a dozen pathfinders.
It's a challenge, to be sure, but we're trying to make it work
Well. growth is always a challenge, but, man, it's the best one to have.
Thanks for checking in, Ken.
Chuck Thornton wrote in to say your blogging insights are some of the best I've ever
heard. Thanks for including me on your email.
You can get on the email too, folks. You can go to scoutmastercgcom.
You can subscribe to receive updates to the blog and the podcast by email.
Heard from Fred Paloso, who is with Cub Scout Pack 66 in New Milford, Connecticut.
He says it looks like your favorite external frame pack is back again.
I found it on Amazon
And Fred's talking about the Outdoor Products Dragonfly External Frame Backpack,
which is my favorite external frame backpack for scouts.
It's reasonably priced. It can grow along with a scout.
The only problem is is that it's slightly ephemeral.
I bought dozens of them over the past 15 or 20 years for our scouts and they work great,
but sometimes they can be hard to find.
So in the post that contains this podcast, I'll share the link that Fred shared with me,
And Fred said he's buying one for his son tonight based on my review.
Well, Fred, I think you'll really like it.
It's one of the best deals that you're going to find for an external frame backpack for scouts.
Well, every week, almost without fail, we try and have a couple of live chat sessions.
These usually happen Tuesday mornings and Wednesday mornings
And if you keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feeds.
I alert everybody to when we're going to be on for a live chat.
A lot of our frequent flyers showed up this week,
but Scouter Irv, who is a scout master of Troop 206 in Oakland, California.
David McGee, who is in New Haven, Minnesota, where he's the chartered organization rep
and an assistant scout master for Troop 911.
And Drew Sterling, who's the scout master for Troop 11 in Albany, Georgia.
all checked in on the chat for the first time this past week.
Like I said, keep an eye on the Facebook and Twitter feeds.
Come and join us for a live chat.
Well, before we proceed with this 290th edition of the podcast,
I want to ask a favor of you.
I hear from a lot of folks every week
And what I'm asking for in return is your support by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
It's very, very simple to do:
Go to scoutmastercgcom, click the support link at the top of the page
And there are a number of options where you can make kind of a voluntary one time
subscription payment to help me keep things up and running.
And this week I want to personally thank Tony Chi and Eric Conley,
who've become backers since our last podcast.
Once again go to scoutmastercgcom, become a backer this week,
and I will make sure to thank you during our next podcast.
Well, in this week's podcast I have some email questions to answer,
And in answering one I'm going to spend a little bit more time than usual talking about
what I think is a pretty pivotal thing for us in scouting,
And that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started. shall we
Send it by name
Email? that is, folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Frank Rodriguez is with Troop 436 in Long Valley, New Jersey,
And he wrote to say: some of the volunteers in my council seem to believe
that failure to have the Boy Scout handbook
with all the requirements initialed and approved
is a reason to deny an eagle at a border review.
I check the requirements and the guide to advancement
and I can't find anything that would support that position.
Am I wrong about this,
Because it doesn't seem right to me.
Thanks for your help.
Well, Frank, it's really kind of simple, isn't it?
If it was a requirement that a scout had their handbook
initialed and approved to present at an eagle border review,
it would be written in the requirements, right?
If you look at the eagle requirements.
it does refer to the project workbook in requirement five
and the application in requirement seven,
but there's zero about the handbook.
Why would the requirements be so specific
about a couple of other documents,
but it doesn't mention the handbook anywhere.
So requiring such a thing is adding to the requirements right,
And we're not allowed to do that.
There is a very simple statement
in the guide to advancement 2015..
It says: no council, committee, district, unit
or individual has the authority
to add to or subtract from the advancement requirements.
So that's an easy question to answer.
How does this kind of thing happen?
I mean, really, you know how does it keep happening?
I'm a little floored by this.
It's really kind of aggravating, isn't it?
How can, like reasonable people sit on an eagle border review
and think that they can deny a scout their eagle
based on the fact that he doesn't have his handbook
and it's not all signed and initialed?
I've run into things like this.
There's two basic solutions to things like this.
First of all, if it's not written in the requirement,
it's not a requirement.
Don't try and read between the lines.
Don't try and add things to the requirements. okay,
If it's not in there, it's not a requirement.
The second solution to this sort of thing
is going to be the solution to just about every problem
I ever hear about in scouting,
And that is simply being a champion of goodwill.
Goodwill is incredibly powerful.
How do you get scouting right?
Well, you be a champion of goodwill.
You assume everybody's acting in goodwill.
Goodwill is a powerful antidote to a lot of things.
A lot of goodwill at an eagle border review
or any border review.
A lot of goodwill at a scoutmaster conference.
A lot of goodwill when we're sitting
and talking to our fellow scouters,
when we're working with our youth leaders,
when we're working with any of our scouts.
We have to assume goodwill on everybody's part,
And I talk about this on a regular basis.
but, come on,
I mean, this is what really makes life fun.
This is what makes being a scouter easy
and makes being a scouter positive
and wonderful and enriching for everybody involved,
including yourself.
You assume goodwill.
Now, your assumption of goodwill may be wrong
every so often,
but it's much less than you would imagine.
If you assume goodwill on everybody's part
and you work along beside them in that spirit,
you're going to get
you. every once in a while
you're going to get burned,
But isn't that so much better
than just burning everybody else
by assuming that they're trying to pull something off,
Right,
You know? here's something Baden Powell wrote.
He said:
Brothers we are to our scouts,
brothers to each other
we must be if we're going to do any good.
A luftness or jealousy could not exist
where there is the true ideal of brotherhood.
What we need, and what, thank God, we have
in most places in our movement,
is not merely the spirit of good nature,
tolerance,
but of watchful sympathy
and readiness to help one another.
We not only need this,
but we've got to have it
If we're going to teach our boys
by the only sound way,
and that is through our own example,
the greatest of principles,
which is goodwill and cooperation.
This next email- well,
this podcast- is being published around
the time of Halloween
and this is a scary,
scary scouting story.
It's okay,
It's all right,
It all comes out fine,
but it's a little scary in the beginning,
And I'm obviously not going to share
any names or identifiers with this email.
But here's the scary, scary story.
I'm the advancement chair for my troop.
A scout gave me his blue card
And somehow I lost them
Before I could record the information.
the scout had earned several merit badges at camp.
The counselors do not retain their part of the card,
So I had all three sections of the blue card
in my possession and lost them.
You can imagine my dilemma: to record
or not to record these badges.
I don't have blue cards.
I remember that you've advised in the past
that we don't penalize a scout
for a scouter's mistake,
but I'm not sure it applies in this case.
I'm miserable about this whole thing.
What do I do now?
Oh my well, I had a little bit of fun with that
and I hope you don't mind.
Listen, it's not a big deal. okay,
Just record the merit badges,
make new blue cards.
note that they're replacements for the ones
that you lost on the troop copy,
Initial the scout section.
do what you usually do:
Give the scout their section
along with the badge. at the next court of honor,
And if anybody ever challenges
how this happened or what happened-
and listen, that is basically not going to happen-
Just tell them you had the originals
but you lost them before they were recorded,
so you recreated them.
You initialed them to show that you had seen
that these badges were complete
and they had the counselor's signature
and crisis averted.
Happy ending to a very scary story.
I mean, there's nothing magical
about that original blue card.
There's no reason that if a blue card gets lost,
that a scout has to go back
and start the merit badge all over again,
or something like that.
In this specific case, right,
the advancement chair had the blue card,
had looked at them,
saw that they were complete,
saw that they were signed,
but just ended up losing them.
And that happens from time to time.
You're not alone,
It happens.
And because they had seen
that these were completed merit badges
with a proper counselor's signature
and they came from summer camp,
so I wouldn't have any problem
of doing exactly what I described:
Just create one,
note it on the card,
lost the original
but saw the counselor's signature,
initial it yourself
and do exactly what I described.
Now, if a scout loses a blue card,
he's going to need to go back
to the counselor,
and if it's happening at summer camp
and they're not keeping records,
oh, now we're in a bit of a problem.
That's a really scary story
But, like I said,
I wouldn't have any problem
doing what I described.
And remember, this is just me,
but I think it's in the spirit of
what we're supposed to be doing
as scouters
And, as you said,
we don't ever make a scout
accountable for a mistake
that an adult makes.
And if you think that
there's any possibility
that there's a record
somewhere that the camp has kept,
well, you can follow up with that.
but let's not wait.
Get the scout the merit badge right away.
That's what's really important
And let's see.
The third and last email question
was a pretty simple one.
Do scouts still retire American flags?
Yes, that it still happens.
Some scout troops
have regular flag retirement ceremonies,
but this is something that
anybody can do, really,
because if you look at the US flag code,
it doesn't really specify much
about this, other than
when a flag is so tattered
that it is no longer fit to serve
as a symbol of the United States,
it should be destroyed
in a dignified manner,
preferably by burning.
So it doesn't have to be destroyed
in some big authorized ceremony of some kind,
because the flag code doesn't talk
about an authorized ceremony
and it doesn't talk about
particular people being authorized to do this.
The controlling thing there
is dignified manner
and preferably by burning.
So if we have a flag
that is no longer fit to display,
we don't just ball it up
and throw it in the trash.
We destroy it in a dignified manner
And, like I said,
check the flag code and tell me if I'm wrong.
but I don't see anything.
I'm sure you can find a local scout troop
who'd be willing to do that for you.
I know the veterans associations
are usually willing to take flags
and dispose of them in a dignified manner.
but there you go.
I hope that helps.
Thanks for listening to this 290th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how you keep in touch.
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and you can receive updates to the blog by email.
by signing up to our subscription list,
You can join all of the other folks
who follow scoutmastercgcom
on the vast panorama of social media.
Join the 10.5,000 folks
who like Scoutmasterblog on Facebook.
Tweet along with the chorus of 1,300 tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the Pultritudinous pictures we proffer publicly
with 2,400 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch us at scoutmastercg on YouTube
And look. you know what?
if you can't do any of that,
if you can't face Facebook and Twitter
makes you better?
you know interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the? U in YouTube,
don't worry.
Alls you have to do is zoom in to the late 90s
and fire off an email.
I am always available at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
And if, for some reason, email is unavailable to you,
if you'll get on the roof
of any ScoutCamp headquarters,
you'll find under a tarp,
a big spotlight that projects a special signal
up against the clouds,
switching on for a few minutes,
and I'll be in touch.
Well, by now it should be abundantly clear.
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of anybody,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by anybody
other than myself.
We're not associated with the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization
for that matter.
It's just me talking into a microphone,
lending a hand to scout leaders
and having a bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of a bit of fun,
here is our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.